pour la route
les 3000
la pression va
tout le monde parte une
dans la vie
j'ai pas fini mon histoire
c'est ma vie
le meilleur c'est la fin
je te préviens
ce triste comme un blue
hommage à
un créneau
si je mens 2 me
remets donc une petite pièce
dans la machine
un peu de musique
ça peut rendre la
tristesse
mois
des ti
écoute bien ce que je te dis
sept chiens de vue
papa d'amy
ah maman
pour mes amis
pour la route
je suis pas une grosse tête
mais une espèce de pareilles
ayant encore un tas de choses que je
n'ai pas dit
je suis bien y a
mais je me sens
quand je pense
tu a rigolé
blatt je sais plus où j'habite
je lui
fais-moi l'addition
merci pour le service
la conversation
c'est comme dans la vie
quand c'est fini
faut payer
les violons
gomez à
l'eau
bon là où
ce don
choc non
m